ANALYST, AND SENIOR EDITOR AT
THE ATLANTIC.
JOE WALSH A FORMER REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN FROM ILLINOIS WHO
HOSTS THE WHITE FLAG PODCAST.
GENTLEMEN, WELCOME BACK.
WE KNOW YOUR HISTORY, YOU
TWEETED AHEAD OF 2016 THAT IF
TRUMP DIDN'T WIN THE ELECTION,
YOU WERE GRABBING A MUSKET,
YOU'VE APOLOGIZED FROM THOSE
COMMENTS.
FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE, HOW DO
YOU VIEW WHAT YOU'RE HEARING
FROM SENATOR GRAHAM AS THIS
INVESTIGATION GOES ON?
>> YEAH, VICTOR, LOOK, TO
PREDICT VIOLENCE AND/OR TO WARN
ABOUT VIOLENCE BUT NOT CONDEMN
IT IS TERRIBLY IRRESPONSIBLE AND
DANGEROUS: AND LINDSEY GRAHAM
KNOWS THAT.
LINDSEY GRAHAM KNOWS WHAT HE
SAID LAST NIGHT WILL INFLAME
PEOPLE AND IS DANGEROUS.
I HEAR THREATS OF VIOLENCE EVERY
SINGLE DAY, AND I WILL SAY
VICTOR, IF DONALD TRUMP IS
INDICTED, THERE WILL BE
VIOLENCE.
I MEAN, LOOK WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6TH.
BUT THOSE THREATS OF VIOLENCE
SHOULD NEVER STOP THE PURSUIT OF
JUSTICE.
THAT'S WHAT A COUNTRY WHO
BELIEVES IN THE RULE OF LAW
DOES.
LINDSEY GRAHAM KNOWS THAT AND
IT'S SHAMEFUL HE DIDN'T
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
>> RON, I WANT YOUR QUICK
THOUGHTS ON THAT.
WE HAVE ALL SEEN THIS HORROR
MOVIE BEFORE AS THE CONGRESSMAN
SAYS.
IF YOU HAVE TO BE WORRIED ABOUT
VIOLENCE, AND OF COURSE WE ARE
AFTER SEEING THE FOAMING AT THE
MOUTH MOB THAT CAME OUT ON
JANUARY 6TH, THEN THAT MEANS
DONALD TRUMP CAN NEVER BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE THINGS THAT
HE'S DONE WRONG LIKE THE GROSS
MISHANDLING OF THESE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
>> THE COMMENTS FROM LINDSEY
GRAHAM ARE REALLY, ALISYN,
ANOTHER MEASURE OF HOW MUCH
POLITICAL AND SOCIAL LIFE IN
AMERICA IS CHANGING IN THE TRUMP
ERA.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, IT HAPPENS DAY
BY DAY, IN A WAY THAT SOMETIMES
IT'S EASY TO LOSE SIGHT OF.
THINK ABOUT HOW COMMON THREATS
OF VIOLENCE HAVE BECOME
THROUGHOUT THE POLITICAL SYSTEM
AGAINST ELECTION WORKERS,
AGAINST PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS,
EDUCATION MEETINGS, MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS WHO VOTED TO IMPEACH
DONALD TRUMP.
WE ARE SEEING AN ABSORBS OF
THREATS OF VIOLENCE, AND TOO FEW
PARTY LEADERS EXPLICITLY AND
UNRESERVEDLY SAYING THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE, INSTEAD YOU GET
THE KINDS OF THINGS LINDSEY
GRAHAM SAID, HE DOESN'T CALL FOR
IT, BUT DOESN'T CONDEMN IT.
BY PREDICTING WITHOUT
CONDEMNING, YOU ARE BASICALLY
INVITING IT.
>> CONGRESSMAN, TO THIS
EXPECTATION THAT THE WIN IN
NOVEMBER FOR REPUBLICANS MAY NOT
BE ABOVE 60 SEATS AS McCARTHY
TALKED ABOUT BACK IN NOVEMBER,
THE PRESIDENT HAS SOME
LEGISLATIVE WINS, GAS PRICES ARE
DOWN.
OSWARI IS DEAD, HOW MUCH OF THIS
IS ON THE REPUBLICANS THAT THEY
WIN WON'T BE AS BROAD AS THEY
PREDICTED EARLIER?
>> A WHOLE BUNCH.
I WOULD SAY MOST OF IT.
LOOK, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
PARTY, MY FORMER POLITICAL PARTY
THAT NOMINATED A BUNCH OF CRAZY,
NUTTY, ELECTION DENYING
CANDIDATES.
AND AS WE'VE DISCUSSED BEFORE,
THAT PLAYS REALLY WELL IN A
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY.
IT DOESN'T PLAY AS WELL IN A
GENERAL ELECTION.
THE OTHER THING IS TRUMP, TRUMP,
TRUMP, TRUMP, I MEAN, WHAT HAVE
WE ALL BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR
THE PAST MONTH.
DONALD TRUMP CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS DOWN AT MAR-A-LAGO.
TRUMP ENERGIZES THE REPUBLICAN
BASE, BUT HE GETS INDEPENDENTS
AND ALL THE REST OF AMERICA TO
GET OUT AND VOTE AS WELL, WHICH
IS WHAT HAPPENED IN 2018 AND
2020, AND COULD HAPPEN AGAIN
THIS YEAR.
>> I THINK IT'S INTERESTING WHAT
WE'RE HEARING FROM SOME
REPUBLICANS, MAINSTREAM
REPUBLICANS WHICH REALLY TAKE
UMBRAGE AT SOMETHING PRESIDENT
BIDEN SAID BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
AT THIS FUNDRAISER.
THIS WASN'T ON THE RECORD, BUT
HE SAID IT OUT LOUD TO THIS
GROUP, AND SO WHAT THE REPORTING
IS THAT HE SAID AT THIS
FUNDRAISING EVENT ON THURSDAY
WAS QUOTE, WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW
IS THE BEGINNING OR THE DEATH
NAIL OF AN EXTREME MAGA
PHILOSOPHY.
IT'S NOT JUST TRUMP.
IT'S THE ENTIRE PHILOSOPHY THAT
UNDER PINS THE, I'M JUST GOING
TO SAY SOMETHING, LIKE
SEMIFASCISM.
WHAT YOU'RE HEARING FROM SOME
REPUBLICANS INCLUDING GOVERNOR
SONUNU IN NEW HAMPSHIRE, THEY'RE
TAKING THE DEPLORABLES, THEY'RE
TAKING GREAT PERSONAL OFFENSE AT
THIS, RON, BUT DON'T THEY
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN THE MAGA
WING AND THEMSELVES?
>> RIGHT.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS
ON STRONGER GROUND BECAUSE HE
ATTRIBUTED THIS TO THE MAGA
PHILOSOPHY OR MAGA MOVEMENT.
YOU ALWAYS WANT TO BE CAREFUL
WHEN CHARACTERIZING LARGE GROUPS
OF PEOPLE OBVIOUSLY AS A LEADER
OF THE COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT AS FAR FROM
ALONE IN VIEWING THE MAGA
FACTION, WHICH IS NOW CLEARLY
THE DOMINANT FACTION IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, THAT IS THE
DOMINANT FACTION IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THERE ARE MANY EXPERTS IN
AUTHORITARIANISM, DANIEL
SEABLAT, WHO WILL TELL YOU THAT
MOVEMENT IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
HAS MORE IN COMMON WITH WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN IN AUTHORITARIAN
PARTIES IN COUNTRY LIKE HUNGARY
AND TURKEY.
2/3 OF REPUBLICAN ATTORNEY
GENERAL FILED A LAWSUIT TO
OVERTURN THE 2020 ELECTION.
2/3 OF HOUSE REPUBLICANS VOTED
TO OVERTURN THE 20/20 ELECTION.
IN MOST OF THE POLLS A MAJORITY
OF REPUBLICANS HAVE SAID THE
AMERICAN WAY OF LIFE IS
DISAPPEARING, TRADITIONAL WAY OF
LIFE IS DISAPPEARING FAST.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE NOMINATION OF
ELECTION DENIERS, IT'S
UNCOMFORTABLE FOR PEOPLE TO DPIT
THEY'RE IN A COALITION THAT
INCLUDES ANTIDEMOCRATIC FORCES
BUT IT'S HARD TO IGNORE THE
EVIDENCE THEY ARE.
>> WE'VE ONLY GOT 15 SECONDS,
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE OUTRAGE AND
THE COMMENT FROM THE PRESIDENT?
>> VICTOR, IT'S RIDICULOUS,
LOOK, I COME FROM THE MAGA CULT.
I ESCAPED THE MAGA CULT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS TALKIN